congratulations on the film thank you
um i think what i loved about this movie
is it's not your typical
teen film you know there's just so much
depth to the story and these characters
is this something that you loved about
the movie
i really loved working on this film and
i think what you said is
is very accurate there are so many
important topics that we touch upon
and we don't really brett haley really
did an important job of
not shying away from those topics and
also
moving on from them as well like
focusing on the idea of hope
but also realizing that hope is hard to
come by sometimes
yeah yeah it was definitely one of those
things that drew me to it um
it's easy when when we're dealing with
the topics that we're dealing with in
the movie and some of the challenges
that amber faces to get into like almost
a dramatic or cheesy or like
melodramatic uh state and i think brett
haley our director did an amazing job at
fi finding the truth in it and not
trying to push it too hard and not
trying to
to over uh this is one scene that i love
in the movie
um big uh not gonna big challenge
nevermind i'm not gonna say it
but it's the way that we handled all the
hard things in the film the way that
brett does it
and the lady as well that i find that
you're right a lot of team movies don't
have and that groundedness and that
honesty
is what really what i really love about
this film yeah
well you and ellie just have fantastic
chemistry in this movie what was it like
working with her
it was amazing yeah we got to spend so
much time together because we're there
we're in portland none of us live there
um you know we're sort of there for a
month and a half and anytime before
not before she she would get up before
going to set i don't know how she got up
so early every day
but after we would get off work there'd
be nothing to do for a few hours and
sometimes we had teams together so we'd
run our lines
um it was really nice we got to explore
portland quite a bit so it was
it was amazing it was really really easy
it's like a dream job
oh awesome well elite i want to know
you know i just feel like you are amber
like i don't know you personally but you
just embodied this character
so much are there similarities that you
have with amber i'd say so yeah
um i really love that amber has such a
hopeful spirit
and he's an optimist um i also related
to her being
like an optimist almost to a fault in
that she
needs to like get real once in a while
especially with those closest to her
uh so yeah i definitely related to her i
also
grew up um with a single mother and so i
i kind of understood that relationship
of
you know it's you and me against the
world so i i thought it just touched so
many wonderful
um heart strings and working with a
really great cast that's neuro-diverse
and non-neurotypical and
differently abled just continued to add
to the realness of our story
well speaking of a dynamic cast can we
talk about carol burnett
absolutely what was it like working with
a comedy genius i mean she's one of my
idols i love her
yes she's so wonderful
on and off screen from an acting
perspective she
just gives her all but also like doesn't
push too hard and
is is so intimate in in her connections
and
i mean i could gush about her all day
but she's also so kind and she said
hello to every single person on set
she also taught me she was wearing in in
the scene
i was like oh i like your shoes she's
like thank you they're mine they're very
comfortable and i was like ah
note wear comfortable shoes while acting
got it people take that for granted but
that's you know you're on your feet all
day
exactly um you know amber
throughout the film really struggles
with accepting help from others so i
want to know
have you guys have moments in your life
where you've had a bit of a hard time
accepting help from others when you
needed it most
definitely for me yeah that's a running
theme in my life
um i i'm i think i'm pretty good at
giving advice and listening to my
friends and then
i'm not good at taking that own advice
so
i'm like awful at it and i've realized
that like in the last year of my life
where i'm like
i really should take my own advice and
like talk to people about my issues and
my brain the things that i'm sad about
or whatever and i just i do
not so it but but that's what the film
sort of talks about a little bit is that
it's not an easy thing to do
but that when you do i found that the
couple times that i have opened up that
i have
trusted someone um some people around me
that i love and that love me and that i
know that
um it does feel better you just when you
lean on someone else it really
you'll be surprised with how amazing
people can be sometimes yeah
how about you ellie i absolutely
um yeah i mean life gets hard
but let's be honest i think all of us
can relate to amber in some
shape or form i am blessed to have
my friends and my family and what we see
in the film
is friends really become chosen family
as well
that they you have a community around
you
so use them when when you need it when
you feel that
kind of heaviness on your heart or that
that feeling like
things are just starting to get a little
bit over your head you don't have to
carry that burden along
yeah i completely agree um well
congratulations on the film you guys i'm
i really really loved it and
randy i just want to say i'm such a huge
runaways fan so
super good thank you
awesome thanks guys see you later